you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 11
from the 2014 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand going into this game Carlson has a
five and a half to four and a half lead
in this race to six and a half points to
determine a world champion and Carlsen
with the white pieces in this one he
opened with e4 we once again revisit the
Berlin defense in this match the one
where the Queen's are off the board
black has the bishop pair and black has
a non castled King and a damage Queen
side pawn structure we've seen this in
game 7 which was a very lengthy game six
and a half hours and we've also seen
this in game nine which lasted just
about one hour in both of those games we
saw h3 is the follow-up and then King to
e8 this is however where things are
different
instead of King II eight black decides
on Bishop d7 which is a tell that this
King is looking to reside on the Queen
side of the board
King c8 b6 and soon enough King b7 so
that's the direction black goes in
Knight c3h6 in game seven and nine we
had this H pawn playing up to h5 by
playing just one step here the main aim
is to keep control over the g5 square
there will be no worry of Bishop g5 or
Knight g5 b3 preparing to fianchetto the
bishop King see a bishop be to c5 very
useful move gives this square our opens
up the square for the light square
Bishop there are also ideas of one day
pressing with c4 looking to exchange
this doubled pawn for a perfectly
healthy B pawn rook A to D 1 B 6 and now
rook F to e1 I think this is already an
important point in the game one might
want to improve the knight position in
this case here but I don't believe that
that would be a good choice here let me
point out an idea that's present for the
black
if I'm this move 14 white is going for
Knight d5 notice how a5 can be played
and as what you want to make sure that
this pawn is not allowed to get to a4
and so if you're playing a for yourself
now notice how there is an additional
move in mind for the black side namely
c4 a4 is no longer defended as soon as
the rook is pulled off of d1 so this is
an interesting way that the Queen side
pawn structure can change in a way that
benefits black I believe you insert this
a 5 move you're looking to get to a4 and
open up the a file if white wants to
interfere there with that with a4 well
he's a potential target c4 is a very
good move so it's important to realize
this idea here this transformation on
the Queen side the pawn structure and
instead look F 2 e 1 if a 5 simply a4
there is no c4 in this case the knight
still has a close eye on the a4 pawn so
after rook F 2 e 1 we have as a follow
up Bishop to e6 now Knight to d5 any a5
will be met with a 4 we do see that
happen in the game but first its g5 this
is doing what exactly well it's securing
this beautiful bishop on e6 how exactly
to get rid of this guy the pawn watches
over f4 what is this no longer do no
longer watches over f6 so now this is a
optically good square but objectively
not doing so much a knight on this F 6
square after g5 if the knight is jumping
in here he's kind of throwing punches
into thin air it's not really hitting
anything nice post he can't be kicked
away by any of the black pawns clearly
but what is he really doing not so much
so this is a very useful move stop
Knight f4 which would eliminate that
strong minor piece blacks we can say
best piece in this position can't get
rid of this guy well what does that mean
that means for one you won't be able to
enter on the seventh rank into this pond
we'll never be able to move in this
Bishop
as it stands right now is kind of biting
on a rock not really doing so much in
the position so g5 very good move
watching over f4 c4 is in anchoring that
night in to d5 he basically cannot be
captured now any capture of the night
this is too much - excellent
pawn breaks available for white d6 or e6
so he's basically screwed right into
that d5 square King b7 king h2 this was
interesting to see during the livestream
King h2 at this point I was thinking how
exactly to do improve do you play g4 and
try to get in King g2 to g3 well white
is taking a similar approach but
changing the move order notice if this
is the end result that you would like to
have for white to have a pawn on g4 and
then slowly improve your king position
notice how by playing King here first
you're making a less committal move
first that's usually a good strategy if
you're questioning the move order or
have two particular moves in mind make
the non-committal move first g4 is the
more committal move without question a
very weakening move just like g5 is very
weakening to these four squares so -
with g4 b - these squares on the white
sky on the white side so it's king h2
for starters as a follow up a v and sure
enough a 497 anticipating that he's
going to be kicked anyway so he looks to
reposition somewhere else these are two
interesting options g4 was played I
thought that there was a reason to not
pull the trigger on this move so quickly
because this night could maybe pounce
into these two weakened squares but
white still goes for that g4 is on board
Knight g6 King g3 Bishop e7 now this was
quite interesting not always the case
you want to allow a knight to pick up
your Bishop but in this case black is
viewing it as well this night he's
really much better than my bishop and
also with this move black does not want
to allow white
opportunity to let's say breakdown at
this g5 pawn if it can happen where
let's say just making a passing move
here let me just back up at this point
right here if black makes a passing move
just to illustrate my point if this
structure is allowed and f GF and e pawn
verses these two split pawns White's
going to be able to erase this guy all
the way up to f5 and eliminate what
blacks best minor piece that's how h4
can impact this position as indirect as
it may seem
h4 may very well be influencing the
bishop on the east c6 square Bishop e7
interferes with this idea in short it
interferes with this idea to play h4 if
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
and white tries for h4 white is going to
come under some heavy fire in what way
exactly well after G takes H Knight
takes age yes these pawns are split but
who's the side who would be more
tactically vulnerable clearly it's white
after f3 there's h5 after let's say
rookie 4 takes takes now it's white
spots for a split light doesn't have an
F pawn there's no fear of this Bishop
being kicked away he remains an
excellent piece the short story here
again is that h4 is basically prevented
with blacks last move Bishop to e7 light
doesn't take him out and instead goes
for something else looks to reposition
the knight on D to look on h2 d 894
looking at that f6 squared looking to
reinforce this knight on d5 excuse me
losing my voice here it's been a long
couple of weeks as a follow up we have
Bishop to f8 Knight f6 and now this
stunning move there were some relay
issues when I was doing the livestream
and this was right around the time that
b5 was played what a shocking move it's
like it's a move that you could be
absolutely blind to right there's two
different pawns I could
that guy right out he's not taken the
move was played the move that was played
as Bishop c3 why is it why capturing
with a takes B well that allows for a
for B takes a rook takes a see force hit
what are you doing
defending your crawling up into a ball
now and this Bishop has prospects of
crashing through on the c4 pun right
you could have Bishop e7 him returning
here to undermine basically the d5 pawn
or the d5 Knight getting rid of a
defender of that square with Bishop e7 a
knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
what are you doing to defend this pawn
it's not a great way to do that black in
short would have a lot of pressure
if a takes B is on board what about C
takes B well there's this cool move c6
don't forget about this King playing a
very active role after B take C King
take C what are you doing to secure your
central knight one attacker to three
rook b8 around the corner to pressure b3
too much pressure too much activity
would be allowed if white is going for
either capture so instead Bishop c3
allowing B takes a B takes a so now
there's some serious weaknesses over
here on the Queen side a lot of isolated
pawns Bishop has direct side of a 5 the
rook is tethered to its defense King c6
getting out of any rook checks and
adding pressure to d5 that's the main
intention it's a lot of pressure on that
point and white needs to be very careful
one to three pieces defending does white
have enough defenders he does with one
two and three so that means that this
rook is not so easily while he cannot
easy easily come over to the b1 square
he has a job right now to watch over the
knight a knight who can still be
undermined further indirectly by this
Bishop on f8 by way of Bishop g7 or even
Bishop to e6 getting rid of one of the
defenders of the d5 Knight so following
up we have King F 3 he's now looking to
play
an active role what a very fighting game
this has been we had play on both sides
of the board here clearly in the center
clearly on the Kings side with King h2g
for King g3 looking for h4 which was
shut down on the black side certainly
some action over here on the B file with
the b5 the B file now being completely
opened a lot of interesting
possibilities here we have the move
played rook d2 b8 this is actually
giving up a little bit of an advantage
here there was a better move for the
black side here in fact the computer
likes the black side with Bishop e7
looking to do what crashed through on d5
so that this bishop has direct sight of
c4 Bishop e7 however was not played if
Bishop e7 was on board what would be the
follow-up there's a couple moves Knight
e3 or even let's say following through
with King e4 what's wrong with Keaney
four there's Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes Bishop takes Knight C takes in
King d6 this is a stable square for the
King this pond needs some attention
needs some defense Knight f4 is not
around not long off I should say from
adding more pressure to that pond this
might be a very good structural shift
for black not a direction he went in
however with Bishop e7 instead rook D to
b8 occupying the only open file looking
at rook b3 placing the bishop in a pin
having a close eye on h3 maybe even rook
a3 getting into that a for pawn king e4
rook b3 was not played as this a mouse
slip it is not rook b4 is on the board
and black is really going all out
allowing this exchange sacrifice getting
what for Bishop takes rook pawn takes
connected past pawns can black pushed
through successfully with this notice
also there's a new square for that
Bishop to finally get to on that c5
square I don't know how great a threat
it would be to this pawn but it's a new
square that's available for both Bishop
and even the King
if you're questioning it all why not
take towards the center well yes he's
still a passed pawn he's a connected
past pawn but there's one less square
for black to work with certainly won't
have the King or Bishop lay here and
white also has a passed pawn as well
not sure if coming over here is the best
but he's capturing tor are away from the
center opening up this Square not even
allowing light to think about having a
passed pawn himself so what followed was
Knight h5 this is paving the way for f4
and then f5 something that black
certainly cannot allow upon to get into
there so he'll be quick to just take him
right out king to b7 getting ready to
give that Knight a kick or in some
variations getting ready to do what
capture on c4 let me point out this
interesting move here suppose suppose
rook to b8 making a passing move after
f4 takes takes takes Knight takes is not
a good idea
well I'm sorry after Knight takes here
Bishop takes pawn would not be a good
idea because of rook c1 and on King to
c5
there's Knight d3 check and well at the
end of it you're dropping the bishop my
main point here of emphasis is that King
to b7 is now going to allow in this
upcoming variation for the bishop to
pick up the pawn on c4 and as a result
it won't then be met with a pin after
rook c1 the king is getting off of the
same file as the bishop by playing to b7
we do have that take shape after your
king b7 we do in fact have f4 G takes f
Knight takes Knight takes and I was
thinking during the game that the King
needed to take but instead the night
takes allowing this pawn to be picked up
there is no rook c1 now to place that
bishop in a pin King b7 is on the board
but what does white do gets to the
seventh rank initially I thought what
exactly is this doing it's attacking
upon that's clearly defended black now
has these two connected passed pawns
does take a while for this guy to get
rolling but if white is not careful
these guys can get rolling and we know
how devastating two puns and let's say
the third-ranked can be they're often
better than a full rook can they get
advancing as a follow up after rook d7
we have rook a6 anticipating more
pressure against c7 and wanting the rook
to play an active role in defensing in
defending the c7 pond playing into c6
here instead of basically crawling up
into a ball on CA to defend he wants
this active defense rook to c6 Knight d5
is on board doing more than one thing
initially I saw it as okay you're
hitting it c7 but what else are you
doing after Knight d5 you're interfering
with the bishops communication with f7
rook c6 has been played rook takes pawn
and now this is a passed pawn the rook
is super active hitting the bishop who
now posts up to c5 rook takes c7 as the
follow-up this is getting very
simplified rook takes pawn rook takes
Knight takes and what do you do here is
black if you take the knight there's
some serious problem it's very clear win
rook c1 one of these guys are going to
fall there's no time for b3 we grabbed
this Bishop b2 under different
circumstances this pawn is going to push
through but not here another piece Falls
and then the rook is able to get right
behind the pawn just in the nick of time
therefore taking the knight not a good
choice instead what was tried as king c6
Knight b5 Bishop takes Knight takes King
takes pawn and now we have these two
guys connected this guy is passed and
with the correct preparation these guys
will also be passed ecigs is on board
b3 it's a big raise King d3 dual purpose
behind that he's looking to hunt down
this pawn he's there to know the rook on
d1 is there to facilitate the e7 advance
Bishop stops that white gets rolling
with another pass pawn h4 a4 it's a big
race g5 h takes G H takes G a3 King c3
and with that last move
we had resignation and non resigns this
one and with that magnus carlsen defends
his title 2014 World Chess Champion
there's nothing to do here this pawn is
attacked there's not a good way to
defend him King a4 is met with rookie
forecheck there goes the beep on these
guys still live if he's ever taken this
guy pushes right through not a good move
here for a team black playing b2
multiple good moves here here's one of
them came to b3
King to c2 is fine as well pick your
favorite way to do it the King is going
to be around to restrain these two pawns
from advancing and again it was at this
point after a very dynamic game another
Berlin defense after King c3 at this
point
Anand resigns and again at this point
Carlsen well with that win has achieved
the six and a half points to required
six and a half points to become champion
final tally six and a half to four and a
half my voice continues to wear and it
can use a break just a couple of quick
things to say thank you very much to
those who have been tuning in there has
been a lot of attention to the posts
that I've been making and thanks for
following along with the livestream I
hope you enjoyed it along the way and
not sure what more to add besides uh I
think this was a fantastic match much
better than 2013 much more closely
fought congratulations to both Vishy
Anand and of course Magnus Carlsen
becoming world champion so that's all
for this video I hope you enjoyed the
coverage and maybe we'll be around again
to cover next World Chess Championship
so that's all for now and as always I
hope you got something on this video
take care bye
you